[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so serries
welt unsere kleine ella moss wird schon
sechs jahre alt leider wo ist die zeit
geblieben oder zum glück natürlich sie
wird sechs jahre alt und sie reitet seit
kurzem ganz gerne und hat sich deswegen
eine pferde motiv torte gewünscht ich
habe ja auch gesagt sie darf sich eine
pferde.de aussuchen wir haben noch ein
bisschen inspiration geguckt aber so
richtig fündig wurden wir nicht und habe
dann gesagt komm ich mache jetzt einfach
so ein pferdekopf und zeigt euch wie ihr
ganz einfach zu einem pferdekopf
zubereiten können am besten teilt ihr
euch das ganze auch auf zeitlich ihr
könnt am ersten tag nämlich den
tortenboden backen und die courage
erstellt und am zweiten tag dann
dekorieren weil dann finde ich bekommt
man es auch ganz gut hin so neben dem
haushalt nach der arbeit nach dem kinder
versorgen ein motiv torte zu machen so
dass man einfach nicht tagelang
stundenlang in einem stück in der küche
steht und hier ist jetzt unten habe ich
einen bananen rührkuchen dann eine
vollmilch genascht das ganze noch
gefüllt mit cookie dough und mit hilfe
einer schablone technik geht das echt
auch ganz ganz einfach also die bekommt
ihr wirklich auch super einfach zu hause
hin hier oben habe ich dann noch so eine
turnier schleife da könnt ihr dann das
alter des kindes oder des erwachsenen
vielleicht gibt es auch erwachsene
unterbreitet hatte möchte am rhein
schreiben und hier dann noch den namen
und das finde ich echt ganz süß also
starte ich jetzt mal direkt mit dem
bananen rohren und zeigt euch mal die
zutaten für den teig nämlich 250 g
weiche butter 250 gramm zucker etwas
salz und vanille extrakt vier eier die
sollten jetzt raumtemperatur haben dann
300 gramm mehl und dreieinhalb teelöffel
backpulver oder ihr verwendet man backen
50 gramm cacau der iss umgesetzt etwa
400 gramm geschälte reife bananen etwas
zitronensaft und milch wichtig ist hier
wirklich das alles zimmer warm ist die
milch könnt ihr sogar ein bisschen
erwärmen und den ofen schon mal
vorheizen auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
und dann geht das ganze auch relativ fix
die weiche butter kommt in die
rührschüssel
oder neben die rührschüssel geht auch
hier musste danach wieder
erwischt
ach ja am anfang geht es mit den
geburtstagen noch recht langsam und dann
geht es an
den rhein
und natürlich vanille extrakt die ela
wird jetzt machen
[Musik]
so hätten wir
nehmen einen teelöffel
jetzt kann ich die butter zucker masse
schön weiß cremig verrühren und in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die bananen
schälen und die dürfen auch wirklich
schon sehr reif sein also die hier sieht
von außen ich weiß die dann nicht mehr
so hübsch aus aber so sind sie einfach
am leckersten wenn sie schön braun sind
die dürften sogar noch ein bisschen aber
ich nehme jetzt trotzdem dazu und dann
zerrt rücke ich sie nämlich direkt mit
dem wacker
ich gebe es hier auch schon mal den
zitronensaft dazu damit sie nicht braun
werden und
dann einfach zu manchen
wenn die masse dann schön weiß cremig
ist gebt ihr die eier nacheinander zu
immer darauf achten ein alter zu geben
schön verrühren damit alles homogen ist
und dann erst das nächste auto zu geben
ansonsten kann es passieren dass die
masse gruselig wird man kann sie wieder
retten indem man was warmes dazu gibt
oder die über ein warmes wasserbad
stellt aber man kann sie auch verhindern
jetzt steht die masse perfekt aus und
jetzt gebe ich einfach die übrigen
zutaten dazu das backen muss ich jetzt
nicht sieben das ist fein genug das
kommt ganz gut ohne sie paus und
backpulver ist einfach schon schön
verteilt
cacau gebe ich auch dazu
das hätte ich eigentlich so ein regal
und ein bisschen milch da gucke ich
immer mal ich habe jetzt 150 gramm aber
kann auch sein dass ich ein bisschen
weniger braucht
sobald mail dazu kommt gar nicht mehr
soviel rühren am besten sogar echt nur
noch bisher unterheben damit der kuchen
schön luftig bleibst und jetzt nehme ich
einfach mein backblech mit meinen
programmen das stelle ich jetzt hier auf
die größte einstellung ein denn ich mag
es einfach einen blechkuchen der bug
schnell durch hat eine kurze bauzeit und
später wird der kuchen sowie so
zugeschnitten der bekommt nämlich seine
pferde form wie wenn man dann noch sehen
einfach kurz bestreichen gleichmäßig und
ab in den ofen und
während der pakt mache ich schon mal
lecker nach leckeren schoko laden
kriegen
völliger nach nehme ich jetzt 300 gramm
sahne und 700 gramm vollmilch kuvertüre
die sahne wird jetzt einfach aufgekocht
und
hier habe ich diese kuvertüre jobs das
heißt ich muss jetzt auch gar nichts
kein hacken falls ihr kurator am stück
habt solltet ihr sie fein hacken oder
auch wachteln damit das ganze einfach
schneller geht und
wenn die sahne koch direkt ausschalten
dann könnt ihr die kuvertüre dazugeben
und am besten die kuvertüre so ein
bisschen runter drücken dass sie
komplett mit der sahne bedeckt ist und
dann schön rühren bis alles geschmolzen
ist und da werde ich sie einfach
umfüllen abdecken um bei raumtemperatur
einfach abkühlen lassen und den kuchen
nämlich auch gleich raus verwalter
fertig ist mach noch kurzen stäbchen
probe und wenn der gar punkt perfekt ist
lass ich den auch einfach abgedeckt bei
raumtemperatur abkühlen und dann gehts
machen mit der deko weiter
das spart man sich so ein bisschen immer
diese wartezeit
[Musik]
der kuchen ist schön abgekühlt und den
kann ich jetzt im prinzip direkt von der
folie lösen die könnte ja einmal sorgt
runter wegrollen
jetzt habe ich hier auf den ab 3 im
pferde kopf ausgedruckt ihr könnt ihn
auch wenn ihr keinen drucker habt könnt
ihr euch das auch aufzeichnen oder so
ein bisschen ab 1000 einfach dass diese
ungefähr eine pferde form habt das
kleinere ist für mich einfach noch so
drauf schauen aber der pferdekopf der
passt so ganz gut und die l hat sich
unbedingt das pferd spirit gewünscht das
ist so einen ganzen film oder eine serie
und das hier ist lucky das ist die ma
und das ist schwierig und ich weiß aber
dass ihr richtiges pferd beim reiten
heißt glaube ich daisy ich musste noch
mal fragen und knicks heißt uns glaube
ich knicks oder nix so irgendwie genau
und die garage ist jetzt auch bereit ich
zeige euch mal die konsistenz
die ist jetzt einfach richtig schön
cremig
guckt mal einfach bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen und jetzt hat sie diese
konsistenz schön streichfähig
und da nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen was
raus in der kleine schüssel
und kann die große menge im abdecken
damit da nichts dran kommt so und dann
geht's eigentlich direkt los
ich habe jetzt hier den kuchen nehmen
eine schablone das setzt sich jetzt hier
außen mal an
ein bisschen tiefer
ich nehme dann auch einfach diese ecke
und das pferd endet dann praktisch hier
und jetzt schneide ich einmal diese form
ganz grob
[Musik]
sollte das drumherum erstmal weg nehmen
und ihr könnt euch jetzt hier so ein
bisschen am bild orientieren das soll ja
schon ein bisschen plastisch wirken also
dreidimensional und das pferd hat
natürlich körperstellen die sind
bisschen dicker und körperstellen die
sind bisschen flacher und ich werde
jetzt hier so machen ich zeige euch das
mal ein
damit ihr sehen könnt welche
körperstellen etwas dicker sind und zwar
würde ich hier
diesen bereich erhöhen
und
diesen bereich
und dann ist alles was drum rum liegt so
ein bisschen flacher und dadurch wirkt
ein bisschen plastischen hier der
bereich ist auch ein bisschen dicker das
heißt alles was dicker ist werde ich
jetzt mit dem restlichen kuchenteig hier
praktisch ergänzen und dann wird das
pferd eben schön hoch
und staffel nehmt ihr jetzt
die ghana
die streicht ihr da drauf
und geschmacklich werde ich das ganze
jetzt noch ein bisschen kombinieren mit
unseren falsches die haben wir jetzt
ganz neu und zwar ist es so eine art
karamellbonbons was man zum naschen
verwenden kann oder man kann es auch auf
dekorieren oder verbacken als ihr können
sie auch im teig drin verpacken das
schmelzen sie so ein bisschen arbeit
geben dem teig einfach nur schöne
konsistenz und ich habe einmal die
cookie dough und einer solltet
kernel-version und ich nehme jetzt
hierfür gucke dann habe ich da so kleine
zeigt sich mal
habe ich da so kleine cookie dough
stückchen und diesem schon lecker muss
man schon sagen
und die kombiniere ich da somit rein
erstmal hier gerne überall drauf
streichen
was wir jetzt noch machen könnte wenn
man möchte könnt ihr auch gerne noch
bananenscheiben mit rein legen falls ihr
es noch ein bisschen banane haben wollt
dann
nehme ich die schablone und
gucke einfach was passt denn jetzt
brauche ich ja diesen bereich hier also
den dickeren
schneide ich ganz kurz zu
schneiden wir uns den bereich so wenig
erhöhen
dann kann ich das gut ausstechen
aufschneiden
[Musik]
und diese reststücke nehme ich jetzt um
diese zwischen parts einfach aufzufüllen
habe ich jetzt die koki das vergessen ja
ich hab sie vergessen
habe ich jetzt wirklich vergessen
ich setzte kurz darunter
vor allem sagen ist kurz vorher noch
und jetzt kommt hier immer wieder
einfach drauf und die restlichen
kuchenstücke nämlich um das ganze erhöht
zu erhöhen und dann wird's gleich
zugeschnitten also jetzt gibt's immer am
anfang so aus als wird zum nach was
aussehen und es wird nie plastisch
werden aber es wird immer mit der zeit
[Musik]
und die danach braucht ihr praktisch
immer als kleber zwischen den einzelnen
kuchenstückchen
[Musik]
guckt mal so langsam nimmt das jetzt
echt eine gute form an und ich nehme
hier immer diese palette und streich
sozusagen die karstadt und was ich an
gar so gut findet deswegen habe ich das
jetzt auch hier auf der torte so die
garage wird durch die kälte des kuchens
ich hatte dir nämlich im kühlschrank
einfach immer direkt fest und ich kann
sofort weiterarbeiten es wie mit
knetmasse dass ich einfach immer schöne
form habe das ganze wird nicht zu weich
und wenn der kuchen doch mal zu weiches
kurz im kühlschrank geben dann wird die
ganz schön fest und man hat einfach
sofort die möglichkeit weiter zu
arbeiten das geht halt echt recht
schnell ihr könnt natürlich auch eine
sahne creme nehmen oder quark sahne
frischkäse sahne aber dann wird das
ganze wird ein bisschen länger dauern da
bist das durch kühlt und ich nehme es
hier immer diese kleinen krümel als er
gleich ist auch tatsächlich fast nichts
mehr übrig das ist der rest und nehmen
einfach die ghana streich alles drum rum
und macht praktisch schöne rundungen
dass die ganzen kanten wechselt und da
schaut ihr euch einfach immer wieder
euer bild anguckt wo vielleicht noch ein
bisschen was fehlt und dann wird der
pferdekopf so recht schön aber ganz fein
müsste nicht werden denn später kommt da
von dampf drauf und durch den fondant
kann ich nochmal diese ganzen
feinarbeiten dann aus arbeiten aber
jetzt sollte die torte gleich so glatt
wie möglich sein
doch immer schön von unten nach oben
schön aus kerpen
das stelle ich die torte jetzt mal in
den kühlschrank damit zu kurz durch
kühlt wird sie gleich noch fertig aus
glätten die krümelchen hierbei war ich
auch noch auf und kann hier kurz
aufräumen und schon mal in der
zwischenzeit dass ich will jetzt einfach
mal eine halbe stunde kühlen und kann in
der zwischenzeit schon mal eine schöne
deko herstellen damit es auch eine
geburtstagstorte wird da muss auch schon
ella und nur sechs drauf damit sie auch
weiß dass es fähig geburtstag ist für
die dekoration nehme ich jetzt fondant
einmal in pink und einmal in weiß denn
ich möchte so einem turnier schleife
machen wie die pferde immer als
auszeichnung bekommen und habe mir
gedacht das mache ich jetzt schön rosa
einmal mit dem pink man sieht auch ganz
gut schaut mal dieses pink habe ich
jetzt noch nicht geknetet das ist
dunkler und das ist jetzt gerade
geknetet und ihr könnt da auch immer
dran denken auch wenn ihr vom land färbt
nach dem kneten wenn es wieder gut wird
einfach immer ein bisschen dunkler und
durchkneten wird sie im ersten moment
bisschen heller
und ich werde jetzt hier einfach zwei
verschiedene rosa töne machen dass eine
pink belasse ich so
dass andere mische ich mit etwas weiß
schön weich kneten und damit das ganze
dann auch die form behält weil von dann
dieser schon so dass es schön weich
bleibt gerade als kuchen über zugs masse
man kann es dann schön durchschneiden
und eine torte damit überziehen aber ich
will jetzt dass diese turnier schleife
schöne ihre form behält und jetzt könnt
ihr entweder blüten passte ein kneten
praktisch eins zu eins also ein teil von
don't ein teil blüten passte oder in dem
10 10 das ist zellulose pulver und
bewirkt genau das gleiche und zellulose
pulver ist gar nichts schlimmes das hat
man zum beispiel auch wenn man sich die
dritten zähne in den mund gelebt dann
ist es auch zellulose pulver und
praktisch lebensmittelecht und einfach
auch als lebensmittel zugelassen
das war wirklich viel und ich nehme dann
immer so einen teelöffel pro 200 bis 250
gramm fondant deswegen dem pc bisschen
weniger
und dann hat man sozusagen der
modelliermasse hergestellt die dann auch
schön aushärtet
ein kneten
jetzt habe ich hier einmal pink zwei
rosa töne und noch weiß wichtig ist dass
ihr die jetzt immer auch abdeckt damit
sie nicht austrocknen
und dann nehme ich hier einfach diese
runden ausstich hat die sind auf der
einen seite glatt und auf der anderen
seite gewählt und jetzt brauche ich
erstmal diese gewählte seite
jetzt schön mit becker stärker einfach
ausrollen
damit nicht klebt
und beckel stärke ist einfach eine reine
kartoffelstärke wenn ihr das ganze jetzt
aus puderzucker ausholen würde dann wird
es einfach irgendwann matschig und
klebrig werden und bäcker stärke lässt
sich später einfach mit der hand oder
mit dem pinsel wieder weg pudern und
dann hinterlässt einfach keine spuren
dann werde ich aus pink auch noch die
was denn du durch die schleife november
unten diese herunter hängen die werde
ich auch aus pink machen
deswegen schon mal englisch ausrollen
da schneide ich jetzt zwei wenn dazu ich
nehme jetzt dass die sec lässt dazu so
kann ich so schön gleichmäßig dick
schneiden aber ihr könnt das ganze auch
mit einem marzipan messer oder mit einem
pizza roller machen achtet nur darauf
dass er nicht mit spitzen gegenständen
auf der silikon matte schneidet sonst
ist die kaputt das war schade
dann schneide ich da oben einmal
glattweg später kann ich es mir noch
kürzen und da unten schneide ich jetzt
ein dreieck rein dann habe ich einen
schönen abschluss
und wenn ihr nicht wollt dass etwas
direkt austrocknet legt jetzt einfach
unter die silikon matte
vergesst nur nicht dass da was liegt
also nicht drüber rollen dann nehme ich
jetzt noch helleren ton
steht dann auch noch mal die zwei kreise
aus
das habe ich hier das alles vorbereitet
und jetzt geht es an die feinarbeit und
zwar nehmt ihr euch jetzt hier diese
rosetten und wenn ihr habt könnt ihr mit
einem rollstuhl das sieht so aus dass
einfach so einen sohn ball hier vorne
dann könnt ihr damit diese rüschen so
ein bisschen ausarbeiten und dann wählen
die sich gleich so ein bisschen nach
oben
was die auch machen könnt ihr könnt auch
zum beispiel ein zahnstocher oder ein
schaschlik spies nehmen das zeige ich
euch auch gleich und könnte damit auch
das ganze so ein bisschen formen
hier mache ich dann so in der mitte du
nicht noch ein bisschen aus und da ist
einfach wichtig dass man sich eine
weiche unterlage nimmt sonderschau matte
zum beispiel und dann könnte den spieß
nehmen hier ansetzen und einfach so ein
bisschen gegen drücken und dann kriegt
doch da auch eine schöne struktur rein
oder in dem modell ihr werkzeug das geht
auch
weil wir sind gefühlte halbe tritt hat
nur besucher
[Musik]
entweder kann man das so machen oder in
dem durch seine modelle werkzeug und
könnte das zu anderen hand drücken
jetzt könnt ihr euch gerne so eine
abgerundete zu schälchen nehmen muss
aber auch nicht da könnte ich auch aus
watte oder zum beispiel küchenrolle
einfach so eine rolle legen und damit
das ganze einfach eine schöne form
bekommt schlägt es jetzt immer so rein
dass es sich so ein bisschen nach oben
wirkt und das trocknet dann auch so
richtig schön an und ich gucke jetzt
erst mal wie es mir gefällt bevor ich
klebe
[Musik]
so finde ich sie
richtig hübsch
dass man sie mal gucken dem inneren
kreis muss ich jetzt kleiner machen
noch kleinere am besten
weiß
ja das passt perfekt und da kommt dann
später die zahl sechs drauf dann sieht
man ganz genau nahm jetzt sechs jahre
alt das klebe ich jetzt hier kurz alles
mit essbarem kleber zusammen ihr könnt
auch wasser verwenden wasser trocknet
einfach ein bisschen langsamer und das
kann bei war es einfach passieren wenn
ihr zuviel nehmt dass das ganze ein
bisschen aufweicht und dann habt ihr
eine noch längere trocknungszeit
deswegen nimmt da ruhig ein bisschen
s-bahn kleber
da reicht auch echt so ein mini tropfen
und dann einfach alle übereinander man
sieht jetzt auch schon ganz gut dass die
gut in form bleiben und das bewegt
ebendieses cmc pulver also diese
zellulose wäre das jetzt nur fondant
wird das ganze sich sofort wieder nach
unten biegen
[Musik]
ich gebe es auch nur in der mitte und
die röschen außen die bleiben dann
locker
was ich bei den schleifen hier noch mal
ich hab so ein kleines pre crash mit so
kleinen ja wieso nadeln drauf und damit
weicht sie am rand entlang dann sieht es
aus als west genäht wir sind einfach so
kleine details die ja doch noch machen
könnte
ich legte es einfach zwischen diese zwei
hölzer dann bleibt schön gerade
[Musik]
jetzt sind die feinarbeiten dran also
einfach mit der restlichen garage und in
krümmel noch habt die torte schön aus
ketten damit wirklich so stellen wir
hier einfach nicht sind denn wenn die
torte schön glatt ist könnt ihr auch den
fondant glaubt drauflegen wenn die torte
unebenheiten hat wie hier sieht die
torte später dann auch nicht so ganz gut
aus deswegen nehmt euch jetzt kurz zeit
und es geht jetzt auch relativ schnell
aber dann habt ihr später einfach ein
schönes sauberes ergebnis
[Musik]
was ich am ende mit der palette nicht
mehr glätten kann glätte ich dann mit
den fingern das geht natürlich nur wenn
die torte schön kalt ist man könnte
wirklich über diese rundungen hier gehen
und auch hier da kommt ihr auf fast kein
küchenwerkzeug rein
und dann kann man das mit der wärme der
finger einfach schön aus glätten
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte in glanz und zum
überziehen nämlich jetzt hier
schokoladen fondant und zwar ist es in
von damit 25% echter schokolade
den gibt es in vollmilch zartbitter und
weiß und der ist besonders gut weil er
einfach zum ersten camper öl enthält und
er hat echte schokolade mit drin das
heißt er von der schmeckt auch einfach
richtig gut und er ist aber nicht so
hart wie schokolade also das ist
praktisch jetzt eine gute mischung aus
moderner schokolade und fondant ich kann
super damit arbeiten haben einen schönen
schokoladengeschmack und eben nicht so
eine pure zuckerschicht und er lässt
sich sehr gut auch in der mikrowelle
kurz aufwärmen falls ihr den zum
beispiel kühl gelagert habt kohlelager
kühl gelagert habt dann kann es schon
sein dass salat ist auch bei fondant
aber wirklich kurz ein paar sekunden in
der mikrowelle perfekt
und ich denke der vollmilch fondant
passt jetzt echt perfekt so als farbe
auf ich meine ich mache jetzt ein
dunkles pferd ich weiß lackiert spirit
ist ein bisschen heller aber ich mache
jetzt nicht das original spirit fade im
winter derzeit mehr
jetzt einfach ein bisschen becker stärke
nehmen und schön dünn ausrollen
als ich muss sagen ich war eben kurz
skeptisch aber anfang weil so ein
bisschen nicht ganz homogen aussah bzw
eine andere struktur hat als fondant
aber der lässt sich echt voll gut aus
rollen was auch schön dünn richtig
geschmeidig
so
dundee gutes pferd
nehme ich dich mal daher was ich noch
machen möchte bevor ich die fondant
decke darauf lege einmal kurz checken ob
alles passt ich meine es passt ungefähr
das passt alles ganz gut
ich will jetzt nach vorne
dann nehme ich mir ein kleines stückchen
troll da so ein bisschen was für dieses
nasenloch
[Musik]
wow
nicht nasenloch müsste
okay
ich bin kein fertig ich werde
jetzt vorsichtig darüber legen und dann
könnt ihr mit den fingern ganz
vorsichtig den von dann schön glätten
und ihr seht schon ich habe ihn wirklich
satin ausgerollt und deswegen ist es
eben wichtig dass darunter glatt ist
wenn ihr den jetzt nicht geglättet habt
dann müsst ihr ihn tatsächlich dicker
ausrollen und das wirkt sich dann schon
auch auf den geschmack aus muss man
sagen und gerade hier unten das schiebe
ich die ganze decke so rein dass es
nicht reicht und dann kann man das ganz
gut mit den fingern anpassen
uns auch hier immer schön an den rand
dran schieben
und dann habt ihr unten keine risse
und am besten immer als die ecken
ausarbeiten und dann diese geraden
flächen und dann kriegt man auch in
jedem alter raus
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch wirklich schön
zeit und fühlt wo er noch luftlöcher
habt die müssen nämlich weggestrichen
werden und dann nehmt ihr euch ein
messer am besten in marzipan messer das
ist schön stumpf und könnten fondant
hier außen wegschneiden
dann auch gerne verkneten wegpacken
luftdicht verpacken und ihr könnt ihn
wirklich mehrere wochen bis monate
aufheben und bei der nächsten torte
verwenden beziehungsweise ich brauchte
ihn sogar gleich nochmal für die mähne
wie heißen die haare beim pferd
okay das hatte ich richtig ich war
tatsächlich ich will es nicht laut
aussprechen aber ich war als kind nicht
so ein pferde mädchen vielleicht auch
weil ich halt mich bei bereiten war und
ich wusste ich hätte jetzt auch nicht
zum reiten dürfen also es war halt bei
uns nicht drin mit fünf kindern muss man
auch sozusagen verweise ich war schon
auf einem reit geburtstag der hat mir
sehr gut gefallen und ich hatte eine
freundin die war beim reiten und dann
durfte ich da ein paar mal mit und ich
glaube aber dass ich keine lust auf
reiten hatte weil ich keine lust aufs
ausmisten hatte ja ich fand so
pferdestall das riecht schon
schon bisher strengen aber die l
bereitet jetzt gern und die gut die
musste noch nicht ausmisten das kommt
halt noch da bin ich mal gespannt darauf
guck mal warum ich mit dem marzipan
messer auch immer gerne arbeitet dass er
weg ist ein stumpfes messer und das ist
halt flexibel also es hat eine gute
bildung ist aber auch nicht so weich wie
so ein silikon und ich benutze es gerne
gerade wenn ich den fondant am rand
wegschneiden denn das sind so die
feinheiten die sonne torte daneben schön
und perfekt machen ich kann mit dem
messer praktisch den vom land weg
schneiden und dann direkt und mit diesem
verschnitt reindrücken den drücke ich so
nach unten unter die torte dass man
einfach diesen abschnitt nicht sieht und
dann zieht die torte rund um einfach
schön und glatz und plastisch aus
[Musik]
es markiert die stelle wo das auge hin
muss
so ungefähr
die haben muss ich sagen recht kleine
augen
so im gesamten und dann kann ich hier
nämlich mit meinem modell werkzeug oder
auch mit den fingern einfach ein
bisschen das rein drücken und schon mal
vor formen
und hier drumherum
einfach auch mit den fingern so ein
bisschen mehr struktur geben das geht
jetzt hier ganz gut weil er von dampf
schön weich ist und durch die finger
wärme kann ich auch hier auf der
oberfläche das ganze noch gut formen und
guck mal mit silikon pinseln die sind
auch vorne schön weich kann ich dann
auch den bund zum beispiel hier
markieren und damit einfach auch feine
linien zeichnen
[Musik]
wenn heute so richtig
so richtig böse werk shop ich mache
jetzt mal das auge ich war grad so ein
bisschen im zwiespalt weil das spirit
pferd hat natürlich so schöne comic
augen und mein produkt fährt das
realistische hat so ganz gar nicht weiß
diesen so dunkel aber ich finde so
siehts kindlicher aus deswegen nehme ich
jetzt bisschen weiß und schwarz und dann
noch braun für die umrandung
also erstmal ausweis
so ein kleines flaches auge formen gar
nicht so riesig wobei dieses betroffen
sind showbusiness triebwerks macht große
augen ganz süß aus
ach ich gucke jetzt mal
so halb realistisch halb
halb comic einfach zu flach drücken
ich leg mal nur hin und kleben kann ich
dann immer noch
groß und hat braune augen
einfach ein bisschen wecker stärke und
dann könnt ihr das nämlich einfach flach
drücken
das schwarz
kreisen und flach drücken
ich finde die augen ist die einzige
richtige feinarbeit der mann hat weil
der rest ist schon recht grob und groß
und die augen da könnt ihr euch kurz
zeit nehmen zum feinarbeiten
und wenn es euch gefällt dann mit frank
leber aufkleben
und dann das auge aufkleben und
schmidt braun und schwarz umrandet
also hier könnt ihr entweder in die
nasenlöcher ist löst dann in den oster
der heißen nämlich ministern könnt ihr
entweder schwarzen fondant kleben oder
später mit schwarzer pulver farbe aus
pulvern so fertigmachen weil mir das
einfach optisch besser gefällt
ansonsten muss man gucken was ihr noch
fehlt
eigentlich sind echt nur noch die haare
die mähne und
vielleicht schreibe ich sogar hier ella
groß drauf
erst mal kurz auf freue
mich dass jetzt nicht macht dann sagt er
bestimmt ab spirit ist da vorne weiß
also was noch
und hinten raus verspielt sich dann mit
so wie sein herrchen und ja das machen
wir jetzt also hier vorne einfach noch
ein paar weiß
untersagt das heißt plätze
ich habe bestimmt in einer community ein
paar pferde
experten ihr schreibt dann einfach wie's
richtig heißt dass klebe ich jetzt da
vorne noch dran
roth da willkommen da ohren dran hier
die mähne und die ohren die werde ich
gleich formen aus der gleichen farbe wie
hier darüber zug ist da könnt ihr
einfach bis zum 10 10 wieder rein damit
die ohren auch schön stabil bleiben und
das hier ist es so bitter es ist schon
verknetet und siedler aus aber das wird
gleich dunkler das heißt die mähne ist
dann einfach deutlich dunkler als eben
das pferd an sich und ich nehme jetzt
einfach immer kleine stücke form die zu
so würstchen
lange und kurze und dann gebe ich dir
gleich dahin
für die ohren habe jetzt zwei
gleichgroße stücke braunen jacke fondant
mit sie prüfe dann vorm ich eine kugel
daraus dann einen großen tropfen
und stehen kann man so ein bisschen
flach rolle so dass er oben einfach eine
spitze hat
die falte ich so ein bisschen zusammen
und lasst sie da mal ein bisschen
antrocknen
und später werde ich das dann mit der
mähne
schön auf der torte platzieren aber
jetzt ist ein bisschen muskelarbeit
gefragt jetzt muss ich erstmal die mähne
komplett rollen
muskelarbeit oder themen arbeit
jetzt kommt hier noch ein geschirr
drüber halfter hat
exakt so heißt es das mache ich jetzt
hier mit schwarz und das werde ich jetzt
auch einfach mit dem cygnet in feine
streifen schneiden gleichmäßig da ist
auch nicht zu dick weil ich finde das
fazit zu echt schön aus und ich will gar
nicht so viel vom pferd verdecken
aber das ist schon ein schönes detail
wobei ich mir kurz überlegt habe spirit
ist ja wild und frei
und braucht es irgendwie gar nicht aber
ich mache jetzt druck dem einsenden
[Musik]
dann wird nämlich 1
hier laufen
genau
und da kommt noch so ein ring darauf aus
metall
ganz so aus von ganz
das vor mich kurz aus schwarz
die sprüche ich jetzt noch mit metallic
sprayfarbe 1
so
las noch mal kurz antrocknen
[Musik]
guck mal hier habe ich jetzt so eine
ecke zugeschnitten und kleine löcher
eingestanzt und das lege ich dann gleich
um den ring herum
fabriziert in s bahn kleber und stehen
streiche sitzt hier auf den kopf damit
ich da die menge an kleben kann da
einfach immer darauf achten nicht so
viel kleber verwenden und nicht dahin
streichen wo ihr gar nichts kleben wollt
also immer erstmal gucken wo was
hinkommt
damit das ganze schön wird
das untere ohr kann ich jetzt schon mal
platzieren
[Musik]
das habe ich hier schon mal die ersten
haare angeklebt für die mähne und stellt
das ganze mal kurz in den kühlschrank
damit fest wird bei [ __ ] muss ich mal
gucken ob das so hält oder ob ich da
später eine stütze drunter bauen muss
das sehen wir gleich jetzt erstmal ein
kühlschrank und dann vorm ich noch mal
ein paar steinchen sind doch einige mehr
als gedacht
jetzt das pferd schon mal richtig gut
aus und ich hab jetzt ihren kleinen teil
nach orange gefärbt mit bisschen rosa
gelb noch rot rein gemischt ich bin
immer wenn ich dann schon eine farbe von
land offen habe und ihm einen kleinen
teil anders braucht von fertig das
einfach kurz ein mann muss ich nicht
jede packung öffnen
und damit werde ich jetzt gleich weil er
sechs jahre alt wird ist eine recht
einfache zahl da kann ich jetzt hier die
zahl sechs hier rein legen
und dann einfach hin kleben ansonsten
könnt ihr aber auch zucker schrift zum
beispiel nehmen und mit zucker schrift
reinschreiben oder auch fondant
ausstechen das geht auch
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt hier die mehr
weitermache bringe ich jetzt auch die
turnier schleife an die kommt ja
ungefähr immer so hier ans ohr
finde ich auch ganz süß und dann kann
ich nämlich hier noch ein paar
haarsträhnen nacharbeiten weiß
eigentlich süßer filmt wenn die weiter
unten hin kommt aber die komponente
ich finde es wird deckt so viel vom
pferd
kommunikation e belege
naja
ich finde das schön ist fährt
ja
ich mache das so ich legt normalerweise
kommen sich hier aufs pferd drauf aber
ich finde es verdeckt so viel vom pferd
deswegen mache ich hier hin und die zwei
bändchen die ich noch ab da schreibe ich
gleich noch happy birthday drauf mit
weißer zucker schrift
ja und dann platziere ich das hier und
hier werde ich dann noch aus
orange oder lila fondant da schaue ich
jetzt mal buchstaben ausstechen ehlers
buchstaben und dann kommt es hier so hin
weil das muss ja gar nicht immer alles
auf die torte drauf sondern es kann ja
auch daneben ja auch so
hab ich gleich wie es mir gefällt aber
dann mache ich jetzt hier noch die
strähnchen fertig und kann hier mit
brauner und schwarzer pullover farbe das
sind einfach lebensmittelfarben die
nehme ich auf einen trockenen pinsel auf
und tupft die einfach in diese schatten
hinein und dann wird das alles so ein
bisschen plastischer
ja
ich mache gerade eine torte für den
geburtstag
[Musik]
meinst du die schokolade
dürft ihr mitnehmen so daran sei aber
nicht so viel essen okay jeder nimmt ein
stück
das wird eine überraschung kriegen ein
kostbarer sonnenbrand
zurückgeschafft gewalt geräumt ja musik
bringt sie mit
[Musik]
laubblätter ganz viele
dasteht gespickt
schnell geriet aufs trampolin springen
geht es der tante
hat jetzt gespickt mehr hat sie mir was
er erzählt hat hat die mich veräppelt
[Musik]
damit das auge jetzt ein bisschen glänzt
könnt ihr entweder ein bisschen back
trance trail auf dem pinsel geben und
dann dieses schwarz ausmalen oder nehmt
einfach ein bisschen metallic farben
dann sticht das so ein bisschen raus
[Musik]
ich hab das gestell hier dieses
geschehen
[Musik]
das hier habe ich jetzt mehr zucker
schrift gemacht und die pflege ich jetzt
einfach da so auf die tortenplatte
hier auch
und so wie es mir gefällt ordne ich es
an schneit hier den rest weg und kann
sogar ein bisschen ankleben und die ella
buchstaben kommen ich hier noch mit
drauf
[Musik]
begleite ich hab mein mann
ich reite ich
[Musik]
heute los war
zum abschluss habe dann gedacht ich ja
wahrlich besteht hier aber ich darf die
torte
nein du darfst du darüber philosophieren
wenn ihr die täter probieren wollte
müsste zum kindergeburtstag aber wenn
ihr zum kindergeburtstag ist ihr
kinderanimation machen tja was eine
chance
naja ich
okay also die torte sitz fertig jutta ja
was sagt ihr so als pferde expertin
man kann wirklich die kontur otto dietz
wer also sarah du musst wissen mutter
hat mich durch dieses video begleitet
und hat mehr viele plastische chirurgen
plastik plastische chirurgin
[Gelächter]
ja das stimmt auch manchmal im winter
habe ich auch nicht
sagt
jedenfalls weiß ich jetzt ein bisschen
mehr europäer weil ich war als mädchen
nicht so ein pferde mädchen du
ja gern aber ich glaube trotzdem hat
sich wird würden sich mädchen wo sie ja
auf jeden fall jungs bestimmt ich wollte
einmal wir machen hier keine gender
debatte daraus ich wollte einmal
unbedingt
reiten und mein papa zu der laufbahn zu
teuer war
genauso
und deine
auf malle also dass man sagen ja wenn
man im urlaub und dann hat er gesagt
dass ein anderer
hat ein pferd nicht schön aber
nicht ein können wir ja gut drauf
gesessen ich durfte ja ich habe ausritt
gemacht ja aber du bist voll gekriegt
hab dann den in spanien ist es egal
ich hoffe einfach reiter am strand
entlang usa und von hier ist ein anderes
pferd mit dem mensch dritte und da hat
halt immer gut da sie nur lebt weil
reiter ist schon nicht so einfach ist
das nicht eigentlich war die grazer und
der vorreiter ist ja die haben ja ihren
eigene kosten und man muss es auch
wissen wie man sie führt ja jedenfalls
hat in zwei tagen geburtstag also ihr
könnt die torte tatsächlich auch schon
drei vier tage im voraus zu bereiten und
jetzt so in den kühlschrank stellen und
die wird nicht austrocknen für zur frage
ja dass ich schon drin
bananenröckchen mit schokolade schoko
ganache und cookie dough fast alles was
ich bin gespannt am sonntag probieren
und ja bin mal gespannt ella wird sie
hoffentlich schmecken ich mache dann
einfach ein handy video vom anschnitt
und vor dem geburtstag weil jetzt im
schnitt können halt nicht machen
jedenfalls war das die torte zur
kinderserie oder zum film spirit schaut
es gerne und es gibt einen titelsong 22
metern kennt
das wäre zum musical artig wenn ich
jetzt einfach singen könnt also doch
schon mal gezeigt ja wir
sind doch wie walt disney oder bringen
und tanzen drei immer wieder druck
braucht sie noch mal eine einstimmung
wenn man mal kurz einstimmte
begleite mich auf meinem bett und sei
dabei ich reite los in die prärie
solange ich direkt anspricht wie noch
nie
also viel spaß nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal
ich bin jetzt gespannt darauf wie er die
torte gefallen wir gemacht
ich hoffe
[Musik]
ja ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute ist ein tag ist dünn geworden
und
vielfältig
machen
seine freunde
[Musik]